A network protocol defines the rules and
conventions for
communications between two parties.
A security protocol defines
the rules and conventions for
secure work communications
between two parties.
So what are these rules and
conventions for secure communications?
That is, suppose Alice and Bob want to
communicate securely over the internet.
What should they do?
They need to authenticate each other so
that Alice knows that she's
communicating with Bob and Bob knows
that he's communicating with Alice.
Further, if they want to
communicate securely,
most likely they want to
encrypt their messages.
Therefore, they need to establish and
exchange keys, and
agree on what cryptographic
operations and algorithms to use.
The basic tools, or the building
blocks of these security protocols,
are the public-key and
secret-key algorithms and
hash functions that we have discussed.